Vsauce five riddles four facts three
misconceptions two projects in one trick
it's five four three two one trick to
try at home
it's the appearing glass you need a
glass with a stem a rubber band plastic
wrap and a cloth the plastic wrap holds
the liquid in while you hold the glass
upside down and you remove it as you
remove the cloth two projects
the first is a homemade magneto helmet
take a red bucket and some purple paper
and go levitate and iron ball soup the
second is a home printer hack that
allows you to print with invisible ink
replace the yellow ink sponge with
concentrated lemon juice and reveal your
secret message with iodine tincture find
the complete steps in the links below
three misconceptions don't eat before
you swim actually eating less than an
hour before swimming does not increase
the risk of experiencing muscle cramps
or drowning that guy has a real Napoleon
complex but Napoleon Bonaparte was not
particularly sure the French emperors
height was recorded at five feet six and
a half inches in modern international
feet which was actually taller at the
time than the average Frenchman bulls
hate red no Bulls are not enraged by the
color red using capes by professional
Matadors cattle are dichromats
so red does not stand out as a bright
colour instead the movement of the
fabric incites it to charge for facts
the sentence the quick brown fox jumps
over the lazy dog uses every letter in
the English language serving ice cream
on cherry pie was once illegal in Kansas
the pound key on the keyboard is called
an octave Thor and the dot that appears
above the letter i' is called a tittle
five riddles a common M is a group of
words that have a common trait in the
three words listed for example a scale a
tire a checkbook are all things that you
balance here are three common ins a ball
of fish a cold a bottle a baseball
player
a mushroom fog a jack a bodybuilder
here's a visual puzzle the objects in
this row have something in common one of
the following three objects is the next
element in the row is an image a B or C
and Y finally a riddle submitted by you
guys as I was going to st. Ives I met a
man with seven wives each wife had seven
sacks each sack had seven cats each cat
had seven cats each cat had seven kits
kits cats sacks wives how many went to
st. Ives to meet your own riddles at
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming and
leave your answers in the comments below
oh and as always thanks for watching